we need to end off on some good vibes  courtesy of tiffany haddish who spent  her holidays visiting her grandfather's  village in eritrea she documented the  whole experience and kept us all updated  on her travel journey take a look and  we'll see you back here tomorrow  bye how good god is okay  it's already been over 24 hours private  jet now  look at god  finance pilots  on my way  to see my family  somebody brought me flowers  that's what i'm talking about  my hair is messed up you've been  stressed all the way out it's breaking  off  but i'm glad  i'm on my way home  see my family put some we gonna put a  treatment on this  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]